machine learning is doing a lot of work
in atmospheric samples thanks Natasha so
actually I haven't done so much work in
addresses or examples I'm really I'm
really getting into into this field
so in particular I will try to give a
slightly non-standard talk on this topic
I will ask you most of you I've seen all
the classical picture so that's why
there is no slides we're just gonna try
to do to talk about the mathematics of
this problem I think it's a it's a
scientifically really interesting
challenge so okay let's let's explain
what is the problem the title of the
talk is nightmare at test time this is
not by me this is by global Sun and
row-wise in 2006 so I guess I'm already
getting old I I long for the time where
you know titles were poetic like this so
I prefer this to Yolo and things like
that
okay so nightmare our test time some
observations about adverse early
examples and really unfortunately what
I'm going to talk about is really not
that deep it's it's a bunch of
observations about the challenges of
address our examples and the opportunity
or so that are present with this new
problem
so what is the goal the goal is to build
robust model
we're robust means with respect to small
perturbation of the input with respect
to small and of course you need to
specify what small mean perturbations of
the input this perturbation happen at
test time as the title indicates that's
that the objective and the surprising
fact is that we don't know how to do
this yet okay so the question is really
can we build robust model with respect
to small perturbation of the input it is
not clear so this the surprising fact as
of 2019 surprising answer rise not yet
okay so deep learning people and there
are many in the room okay it's recorded
so I should be a little bit careful but
they claim they can do anything so if
there is one thing that they cannot do
is this so just to to clarify what we're
talking about if you look at C for 10 or
imagenet so these are the most popular
data set right now for deep learning the
state of the art as of now is 57 57
percent accuracy with I will explain
what this mean with epsilon equals 8
okay so we cannot get the 100% accuracy
that we've been talking about for
instance in JSON stock you know you just
feed your data and it's just perfect for
this address or example it doesn't work
okay so what is this epsilon equals 8 so
again the C for 10 data set it's a bunch
of images you know which which have a
certain size and each pixel has 255
possible values and our three channels
RGB and this epsilon equals 8 means that
you can change the value of each pixel
by at most eight okay every one of them
this type of preservation is in
imperceptible sorry to the human okay
you cannot see such small perturbations
so as a human you just don't see
anything the image is exactly the same
to you okay and we cannot get 100%
accuracy or 90 or something like that
right so yeah yes of course yes this is
test and maybe I should say a little bit
about okay so maybe some ground rules
for citations citations are very very
tricky business in deep running and the
reason is so many people are looking at
it right now that you know there is a
lot of overlap lots of people come up
with the same ideas particular or not
nobody has come up with anything deep in
adversarial examples so everybody is
coming up with the same thing so that's
very complicated also the groups are
very big and there is usually a first
author who did the work and then there
are some more famous people on the paper
so it's it's really really really tricky
to get the right citation but there are
still a couple of papers that stand out
so this number that I got is from Jiang
guitar 2019 but one papers that
definitely stood out is Madri guitar
from 2017 so the point is that there has
been a lot of work on this already since
a paper in 2013 by Sogeti natal which
was the first one to notice this issue
that neural networks are very brittle to
address all example so since then there
has been a lot of work and Madri Attar's
paper was the first defense to the first
you know actual algorithm that produced
a certain test accuracy which was not
broken so nobody has been able to bring
down the test accuracy of that model to
zero meaning all the other paper were
broken okay so all the other paper
working yes
unlike all the other sedation it doesn't
be the first a little bit all the world
okay okay thanks yes okay very good
yeah so you didn't know but yeah this is
good
so this stood and basically people are
building on this address or training
address or training was also introduced
in 2015 we're going to talk about it
towards the end and for imagenet let me
remember what the number forty three
percent and forty three percent and
that's a group of people at fair and i
will try to explain very briefly what
the other okay so this talk is not going
to be about those papers it's not going
to be about those numbers i've use this
as an extremely interesting engineering
challenge but what i'm gonna try to do
is to focus more on the science of
address or examples and it's extremely
limited we don't know much so what i'm
gonna do is that I'm going to go through
some examples that illustrate to put the
difficulties a couple of basic serums
and yeah and and and then we will
conclude with state of the art
techniques that could fall out of
everything that I would say that get
numbers close to this even provably okay
so that's that's going to be the N so
the talk so what the talk is about it's
about five observations which are going
to be the following I still haven't
defined exactly what we're doing but
don't don't worry it's coming so the
talk is about five observations the
first one is that when you try to deal
with these addresses are examples of
meaning building this robust model to
small perturbation it is a completely
different game from the classical
statistical learning theory
okay so first observation is it's a
different game
you really need to think about adversary
example you cannot just train something
and hope it's going to be robust it's
just not going to work the second
observation is going to be that you
probably or maybe need more data to to
have the same kind of performance you
might need much more data the third
observation is is that you need more
compute the force observation is that
anywhere we're probably doomed doomed
anyway even if we have more data and and
more compute and the last of salvation
is but at least we can certify it at
least we can certify it okay so that's
that's going to be the plan maybe before
I get into the mass and the examples a
couple more words about the motivation
for this the motivation is actually no
joke at all I mean this this is a very
critical topic for today's you know ml
business and AI business for the
following reason so ml is is becoming
applied more and more in the industry as
as you all know and when it's applied in
the real world there are agents that are
going to try to game the system and if
your model is not robust then it's going
to be very easy to game the system so we
have already seen example with these
adverse or graffitis for autonomous
driving I mean when I saw that I really
at that point I didn't want to get into
a self-driving car for real I mean
reading somebody can put a sticker on
the stop sign and make you know the
system believe that whatever there is a
road where there is no road okay so we
we have to be very careful with that
another one just recently there was an
article in The New York Times about
medical machine learning and how
insurance companies are very worried
about all of this because imagine that
you have a system which is deployed like
an insurance system where you you know
you you submit your claim and then there
is some automated the ml systems that
process the claim and then tells you
okay you get that
money if I have access to this model and
I know how to game it how to change one
word you know in my in the claim that I
submit to make it so that I get more
money this is a real problem for the
insurance company but in fact it goes
back way earlier and people in machine
learning have known this for a long time
so again this this goes back to 2006 in
fact there is Darvey at all 2004 which
is about spam filters so spam filters is
a very good example where you train your
model on some you know large collection
of emails and maybe on this collection
of emails there are some keywords that
are extremely predictive of whether it's
a spam or not I know maybe there is a
royal families that appears in every
span something like that but then once
you deploy the system you know the
people who are creating the spam they
know about what you have deployed and
they can identify the true classifier is
based on this then they just remove this
feature you know you they don't say what
royal family anymore and that's it you
you're not you know you won't have good
accuracy so it's really a game between
the person building the classifier and
and the adversary's who are trying to
gain the system okay so that's I think
all I wanted to say for the motivation
so now we're just going to define the
problem and grow through a bunch of
examples this is a definition we are in
the statistical learning theory
framework okay so SLT framework that
you've seen in Peter and Sasha stock and
we add one ingredient and the ingredient
that we add is a relation plus a
relation which is a subset of X cross X
okay so this is the the set of inputs
and what this means is that just if X X
prime is in R then X prime is an
admissible perturbation
so this is extremely general and that's
the only new ingredient that we add to
the problem now what we're going to
define is the adverse or loss so the
adverse or loss so again we have a
hypothesis H and we have a pair of
example X Y so the adverse or loss is
just the supremum over all X prime such
that X X prime is in the original loss
function which is part of your standard
SFG framework of H on X prime logic so
instead of looking at whether you make a
mistake when you try to predict Y using
a X you try you see whether you can make
a miss you make a mistake when you try
to predict while using X prime which is
a small perturbation of X and now the
game is just to find classifiers
which are good with respect to this
measure in exactly the same way that's
all that's the only difference
okay so in this talk what we're gonna
focus on we focus on relations which are
non base relation but I want to
emphasize that non base relation are by
no means the only interesting things I
mean this goes way beyond just non based
notion of closeness but that's what
we're going to focus on so we focus on R
which is a set of pair xx prime which I
in all my examples are going to be in
abdi such that the norm of X minus X
prime is smaller than some epsilon which
is set in fact we're even going to focus
mostly on the L infinity norm okay which
is where this number came from suppose
the elite fit you know so mostly and
infinity and we will also talk a bit
about l2 because our good nice reasons
to to talk about it yes
many choices could make you wise well
what would be another option
ah no no okay
so sure so think of it yes you're right
you could think of the average the
supreme um just means the following you
look at your ex maybe your predictor is
perfect on X on the input X but you want
it to be good in in the neighborhood of
X not only for the image but for any
small perturbation of the image so this
is going to be big if there exists a
small perturbation of the image for
which it's big the average would be
another notion of robustness which is a
different notion of robustness yeah okay
thanks all right so now let's let's go
to show those things so the first one
the fact that it's a different game it's
kind of a city but it's worth pointing
out so imagine the following example so
this is going to be example 1 X PRIZE is
a little bit of rotation of X and isn't
it the difference between two images in
the
would be larger than that yeah of course
so again I emphasize that here so I
focus on L infinity because it's going
to be simple and it's gonna give me some
interesting statements but I'm not
claiming that this is a right norm for
images
I never made such a claim you might want
to look at it in buses time distances
yeah I this is this is not this is out
of the scope of this talk how many
things out of the scope of this book I
mean there is an entire field to be
developed here okay so example one is
very silly but okay so X is gonna be
like this so it has two components the
first one is a point mass it's a Dirac
at epsilon Y okay so so all my y's most
of my y's is I'm going to do binary
classification right so Y is going to be
minus one or plus one and I'm mostly
gonna look at binary classification so
the first feature gives me the label
tells me what it is and so the second
one is something like this 3/4 a point
mass at y plus 1/4 a point mass at minus
1 okay so we port is 3/4 this tells me
the label and if for the one false it
tells me you know the opposite all right
so what is this thing this is saying
that if I want clean good clean accuracy
I should focus on the first feature but
the first feature is very brittle right
I can just make it disappear or you know
inverted by just moving by 2 Epsilon
okay so to get good clean accuracy
Jews feature one but zero robust
accuracy just it is absolutely not
robust okay on the other end to get good
robust you want to use feature too but
if you do that then you hurt your clean
accuracy
okay so clean is now 75 percent so this
is kind of an obvious statement to make
but this is saying something about those
numbers you know they look bad compared
to the clean accuracy but maybe it's
inherently like that maybe we cannot get
better than this it's not clear at all
you might complain that the scale of the
first feature is very tiny so it's
extremely artificial etc so let me just
modify this for you
example one prime this is in a paper by
tsipras 18 I mean it's very easy I can
just replace this by a bunch of
gaussians okay so replace feature 101 by
a lot of gaussians of mean epsilon and
say variance 1 epsilon 1 okay so if I
have a lot of gaussians like this I can
just average them and this will give me
Y but again this is not robust if I have
any combination of those things
I can kill the bias by just doing a
small and add infinity perturbation in
each of the coordinate
all right so the moral of this is just
that clean accuracy I mean you might
hurt your clean accuracy when you look
at the robust setting and moreover when
you look at the robust setting you
definitely don't want to optimize for
clean accuracy that's just the wrong pin
good so another point that I want to
make in in the fact that it's a
different game is that we might also
have to look at different architectures
or different type of classifier so again
it's kind of obvious and by the way pins
get slightly more interesting as we go
on don't worry too much so the second
thing that I second examples that I want
to say it's just that might be is that
you have a class of functions that works
very well for clean accuracy but it's
terrible for for robust so let's let's
look at an example so what do I want to
do here I will do the same thing again
point mass at the epsilon Y and pause
the second one I'm just going to do
something like this I will add the
second coordinate is an integer and if Y
is equal to one odd integer odd number
and if y equals zero an even number okay
so this this is my my input distribution
so just a picture is like this you know
I have I have a plus 1 here then I have
a minus 1 here and I have a plus 1 here
a minus 1 here plus 1 minus 1 ok so if I
want to do clean accuracy I have just a
very simple hyperplane here I'm in a
simple line that separates the two but
if I look at the robust accuracy the
problem is the Box like this any line is
going to intersect a bunch of them okay
I saw it intersect a bunch of them or
it's not it doesn't have good accuracy
so then our classifiers they cannot do
well on this example ok so linear
classifiers get 100% clean and zero
robust of course the right thing to do
is to do something like like this
whatever you see what I mean ok so you
need to look at the more complicated
class of functions if you want to get
good robust accuracy so you might say ok
you might be unhappy with this example
ok first of all you might say you're not
like this we have already seen how to
deal with that and you might say ok it's
not very natural this or that even
integer of course it's it's going to be
bad for linear classifiers so let's just
do very quickly an example to prime and
then we move on to the to the rest
example 2 prime
what I'm gonna do is just X is going to
be an iid sequence so bunch of
identically distributed features which
have the following distributions one
half plus epsilon five months at y plus
one half minus epsilon point mass at
minus y ok so I just get a bunch of
conflicts but they are slightly bias
towards the truth okay so of course a
linear classifier I just average all of
them is going to give me the truth but
any ninja classifier I can it has a
certain bias toward the truth but I can
kill this bias by making an infinity
perturbation now how do I recover from
this if I do if I'm in this example you
see I only see Plus Ones and minus one
if the adversary wants to kill the bias
of this classifier is going to step
outside of the natural classes instead
of having minus one and plus one I'm
going to have something like 0.9 or
point zero one so what I could do as the
architectural designer is that I could
just remove this address or noise by
rounding okay so again Nina pass favor
don't work so there is a simple fix
simple let's say nonlinear fix which is
round before the linear classifier so
this is like the baby super baby version
of denoising okay which is a very
natural idea that you want to that you
might want to explore in fact the fair
papers that I cited which attains 43
percent on imagenet is using you know a
denoising idea to try to defend okay so
this this is real this is something that
we might have to do in reality okay so
that's all I wanted to say for for the
fact that it's a different game so now
we're going to move to the more data is
there any question on this point one
okay so let's move to the more data
and here I'm gonna use the fact that you
have listened very carefully to Peter
and Sasha and you know everything about
vc-dimension and rather macro complexity
and all of those things so we're just
gonna analyze those objects for the
adverse or loss and compare it to the
regular loss is more data so let's say
first vc-dimension adversarial ok so
again what I mean just to clarify you've
seen that in a Peter and Sasha stop you
have the lost class L which is a set of
functions that map X Y to L of H on X Y
4 and I put this in your hypothesis
class ok so what you care about when you
want to do uniform law of large numbers
and you know evaluate empirical risk
minimization or any algorithm for that
matter you want to analyze the
complexity of this last class now here
what we have is a loss the address or
loss class which is a set of map from X
Y to
L adversarial H on ok so you might want
to ask just how do those measure of
complexity compared for these two
function classes and again to clarify
when we talk about VC dimension we talk
about the loss class which is the loss
function is just zero one knows and the
VC dimension you remember it's I can
find a set of points it's a larger set
of points which can be completely
shattered meaning that I can get any
signed pattern for the loss function ok
so similarly the adverse or VC dimension
is going to be the largest set that can
be shattered by this object meaning that
the adverse or loss can take any sign
pattern so that's the definition of the
address or a VC dimension so here is a
simple claim
which is in a paper by montasser hanneke
and nachi I think it's 19 and there is a
very similar construction in who denied
our 2018 so the claim is like this the
exist in hypothesis I mean the claim is
supernatural but it it's worth pointing
out the exists of our lost class such
that the v c-dimension of h is one so
let's say for any d big or equal to one
there exists or lost classes that the v
c-dimension of h is one and the address
or v c-dimension of h is d so they are
just completely unrelated and this can
be for this setting for the relation
which is just the i'll infinity norm and
we're in dimension D it's nothing
nothing credit so let's do the
construction of this
but just to clarify a point this is bad
news
right this is saying that you might have
you might have a nice class over which
you can generalize very easily for the
classical setting but you cannot you
don't generalize in the uniform law of
large number sense for the address or
case for what Epsilon
this is for any Epsilon the proof I mean
let's do the construction very simple so
what I'm gonna do is that I'm gonna pick
a bunch of little cubes like this so
this is let's say you know I have the
line like this this is I I in n and this
cube is just I you know I plus epsilon
times a cubed okay and I have a bunch of
those things as I have G of them okay so
I have a bunch of little cubes and this
this is this is my input space now what
is my last class the last class is going
to be the following for any be in minus
1 1 to the D I will define an iPod esses
which depends on B and which takes the
following value so let's say I plus
epsilon Delta prime this is the
following things so it's plus 1 if Delta
prime is equal to 0 ok so my hypothesis
always predict plus 1 at the center of
those cubes okay so those cubes I know
it's plus 1 there is no ambiguity there
now it's gonna predict Delta sorry it's
gonna predict B I
if if Delta Prime you see what I want if
that the prime is equal to B okay so if
I'm looking at the corner of the eye
cube which corresponds to this encoding
of my hypothesis then I predict the bit
B I okay so it's either plus 1 or minus
1 and it's plus 1 otherwise okay so
notice that in particular if bi is plus
1 then this is just predicting plus 1
everywhere if all if all of them are
plus 1 that is predicting plus 1
everywhere and is predicting plus 1 on
all all the cubes where this index is
plus 1 the rest let's analyze the VC
dimension and then resolve VC dimension
they want the v c-dimension of h is
equal to one minute yeah yes i goes from
1 to d I wanted
I mean yeah okay so the VC dimension is
one
why is that okay I want to look at the
largest set that I can shatter so let's
say that I can get a value minus one
somewhere I can get to minus a value of
minus one someone let's let's say I get
a value of minus one here okay if I'm at
this vertex and I get a value minus 1
here then I know that B is equal to this
okay so if HB of I plus epsilon delta
prime is equal to minus 1 then B is
equal to Delta prime so I have fixed
everything you see if value minus 1
somewhere fixes the value everywhere so
I can just I can I cannot shatter and
anything except a set of size 1 on the
set of size 1 I can get value plus 1 and
minus 1 but on any other set I cannot
get all values because as soon as I get
to minus one somewhere it freezes the
value everywhere but what about the
address or DC the other service I can
get anything because I know that the
value on those things is always 1 and
let's say I want to get an address or VC
of you know I want to get an error here
no error here and there or you know and
so on and so on and so forth I have some
sine patterns that I want to get what I
can do is if I want an error here I can
just set you know this is I can just set
VI to be minus 1 and then this one let's
say this was 1 this is 2
so I said B 1 to B minus 1 B 2 to be 1
so B 2 is 1 then I know that it's 1
everywhere on this cube so there is no
address or mistake here if B 1 is minus
1 here then I know there is an address
or mistake because this guy is minus 1
when this guy is 1 okay so I can get any
sign patterns that I want them to is
what I just explained that the address
of EC
in fact Italy in business okay so but
it's you know it's not surprising at all
I mean the VC dimension
it starts with it's just a combinatorial
property of a bunch of sets now we've
added this relation R which has nothing
to do with those sets so of course it's
not going to be appropriate there is
going to be a mismatch between the two
just doesn't type check so it's not
surprising but you might say okay this
was a very weird I put is this class so
at this level of generality you cannot
say anything and it's true so let's look
at something simpler and that we like
and we can understand a lot of things
through them which are linear
classifiers and we'll see a lot of
interesting things so too
what about something simpler
in our classified
okay and here I'm going to look at a
more sensitive notion of complexity
which is a rather macro complexity okay
and this is taken from two paper what
did I write it came and OH 18 and the
other one is a Peter
so yang comes undone okay it's very very
simple I mean maybe it's too many people
assigned to this but they I mean they do
more in those papers than what I'm going
to say okay so we want to look at the
rather macro complexity of you know a
class which is the set of
is H where H just a bunch of you know
dot maps to W in a product with dot okay
W is in some sense IV okay so this is my
set of classifiers just mean our
classifiers and you remember from Peters
dogs that you can apply the contraction
lemma so here now we're gonna have the
following else yeah this is a random
acro complexity it's not the relation
yes very good thanks okay that's that's
good yeah I will be careful with it so
if I look at the classifier W dot on an
example XY this loss in the linear
classification is just some other
one-dimensional loss function a lower
bound of Y applied to W dot X where a
lower bar is just let's see so if I can
manage to make W X to be of the same
sign as Y and very big I'm very happy so
L is decreasing and hell can be whatever
the hinge loss or you know cross entropy
or whatever you want
I mean logistic loss I guess okay so
this is the setting that we're looking
at we're looking at this loss function
and I guess what I want to say is that
the rad maker so let's write it rad so
the Rademacher of the last class L which
is this lost class so also classifiers H
which are like this this is bounded like
that so L is decreasing and one
Lipschitz
okay so what we're gonna focus on is
this thing that's a clean accuracy so
now let's see what happens for the
adversarial case okay so for the a
dresser case we need to look at what
does the adverse or loss look like is it
also some Lipschitz function of
something simple let's do a very simple
calculation
[Music]
so we want to know what is the adverse
or loss of w.com the pair XY so again
this is what this is a supremum over all
let's say perturbation delta such that
the norm of Delta is smaller than
epsilon off the loss and lower bar of Y
applied to W dot X plus Delta that's my
definition of the address or loss and
just look at I make it as big as
possible when I add a perturbation data
of size at most Epsilon now I said that
this is decreasing okay so I can put
this supremum inside with an infimum
okay so this is equal to L bar okay
there is one part which doesn't depend
on Delta then there is plus the infimum
over delta such that the norm of Delta
is more than epsilon of why W dot Delta
but this is just the definition of the
dual norm because this is just going to
give me the direction how how much can i
decrease w the Delta when Delta is
constrained to be of norm bonded by
Epsilon the value of this is exactly the
dwarf W so this is equal L bar why W dot
X there is a minus sign because it was
infimum minus epsilon times burnham
ultimately of course it's not at all
surprising that we get this dual norm of
W that comes in this exactly corresponds
to the margin in this known how far is
the example from the decision boundary
whereas the notion of file depends on
this known ok so just the picture if
this is my decision boundary and I have
this point this is the closest point in
L 2 but when I grow an infinity balls
I might get here okay so this gives me a
different direction
this is like the conjugate direction
okay very good so so this is my address
or loss now you see I will be able to
apply the contraction lemma
and the only thing which gets different
is that instead of having the radical
complexity of the linear class I will
get the red marker complexity of this
class the class of functions that map
the pair X Y to Y W dot X minus Epsilon
the door norm of W what is the rather
macro complexity of this class and how
does it compare to the original rather
macro complexity okay so that the next
calculation that we are going to do let
me also point out that if you naively
look at this in the W space this is non
convex it's or it might be non convex
this might be non convex in W so this is
kind of foreshadowing this more compute
here the Third Point which is you
started with something very nice convex
in our classification and when you look
at the adverse or loss you immediately
get something non convex let me say this
is very artificial in fact this is
convex you can lift this program to make
it convex so I won't write it down it's
very simple you just introduce a
variable s for this thing and then it's
convex in s and the inequality that is
defined on s is also a convex inequality
so in fact this is a convex program but
if you're just in the mindset of just
running gradient descents on the
parameter space you're going to be in
trouble it's not going to work and this
is a real issue like address or training
which I will talk about does this it
just goes straight for the W space but
it might be that there is a more
appropriate transformation that kind of
changes the landscape and make it more
appropriate for optimization so we will
talk about that briefly okay
now
they want to compare to quantity to
quantity first quantity is this rather
macro complexity so the clean Rademacher
is just 1 over n the expectation of the
supremum over all w in this set script w
of the sum for I equals 1 to N of Sigma
I which is our random sign of W applied
to X I right you remember this was from
Peter and Sasha's talk hopefully this is
the clean Rademacher for linear
classifiers which if W is just a ball a
norm of W ball this quantity is just 1
over n the expectation of again just the
drawer norm of the side some for I
equals 1 to N of Sigma I X I this is a W
door ok so this is a clean Rademacher
and I think you've done estimates on it
in the case where it's l2 and things
like that
ok so now what is the address or
Rademacher the address our Rademacher is
just I replace W detects I by this
function because why I doesn't matter I
can absorb it into the noise so it's
just 1 over n the expectation of the
supremum over w let's say again it's a
norm of W let's say I'm going to write
the P norm is going to be simpler ok so
this is an assumption and now look at
board in LP norm of the son for I equals
1 to N of Sigma I of what W dot X I
minus epsilon times the door norm of W
well this do or norm is the door norm of
the address for example which in our
case we look at an infinity so the door
norm is going to be L 1 so we're still
over
yeah so the Elendil score I've removed
it because I applied the contraction
demo right so again I did this step
right where instead of looking at the
rather macro complexity of the last
class I look at the writer mark of
complexity of the hypothesis class
because I have a Lipschitz one midgets
loss okay so all I need to do is to
compute this quantity and compare it to
to this one this calculation and then
something something nice comes out again
you will see a dimension gap okay you
will see that the dimension appear just
like it appeared in our BC bow what did
you do something in applying that it
because you're trying to show a lower
bound for the sprite yes good yeah
you're right so I will so let's go with
upper bound for the moment and then I
will give you a more convincing lower
bound but it's pretty tight so yeah but
you're right you're right I did apply an
acrobat okay so let's let's see this so
again the supremum over W such that the
LP norm of W is smaller than one and
let's give it names of this quantity so
I have you the W minus V times the one
norm of V what is U u is just the sum of
Sigma AI X I and V is epsilon times the
sum of the Sigma okay these are the two
quantities and that's the thing that we
care about so I'm just going to write
this as W inner product with u minus V
times the sine of W
that makes sense now you see if I want
to maximize this thing when I look at
here the sign of the component of W
doesn't matter here it only matters here
but here if I want to maximize the sign
of W is going to be the same thing as a
sign of you
I want to correlate those two things in
fact this sign of W this is a sign of
you when you maximize at the optimum the
sign of W is equal to the sine of U now
I have a supremum of W of W in a product
with something that doesn't depend on
that value so again it's a do or non
thing this is equal to the door norm of
the LP norm of this quantity which is
just the enqueue Nam so this is u minus
V times the sine of U and you know this
is just the difference here I just add
the norm of U and now I have u minus V
times the sine of U so I can just apply
the triangle inequality I guess the norm
of U you know plus you know the norm of
V times the sine of U okay so this is
with my clean Rademacher
and again you might complain that here I
did an upper bound but in fact it's very
easy to see that this quantity in
expectation with respect to everything
it's a folder of this it's also lower
bounded by one half that because this is
anti symmetric in the Sigma's and this
is symmetric in the Sigma's so you can
just apply you know whatever the
triangle inequality and you will get
that this is larger than one-half of
that okay so I won't do that but it's of
the same order so we get that the
address or Rademacher is a folder of the
clean Rademacher plus a new term now
what is this new term okay V it is just
a real number
it's epsilon times the sum of the Sigma
I which is of order epsilon times Croton
it's just the typical deviation of this
thing the only vector here is the sign
of you it's a bunch of you know plus 1
and minus 1 now again
action or mug that so that's just you
know I get a bunch of of things that I
some I get D of them to do one over Q so
this is a folder D to the 1 over Q sine
squared n okay but really I have a 1
over N normalization so what I get is my
address or Rademacher is equal to my
clean Rademacher plus d to the 1 over Q
over square root n so I get another term
in the address or Rademacher which
depends on the dimension so if you were
doing something naive and you just do ad
to regression you would get the square
root G over N so you get something that
dimension dependent where this guy is
dimension free in the sense that if
everything was bounded in there too it
would just be 1 over square root n of
course notice that if you were to use in
your function class P equals 1 then Q is
infinity and you don't get an added term
okay so this is kind of telling you
something about how regularization you
know should be aligned with the adverse
old norms that you're trying to protect
against which makes a lot of sense you
just want margin in the right now but if
you're not careful you get some positive
dimension dependency in the
generalization okay so again this is you
know you you can argue whether this is a
convincing lower bound it's at least a
very good upper bound but let me now
show to you a very convincing lower
bound which in fact goes beyond any any
class of model okay it's just it's going
to be an example where you probably need
more data okay no matter what you do
but yes yes good Dino is there how does
it answer in the calculation
suppose I have I know somebody knows the
distribution and can can process experts
before giving it to the classifier
yeah
I guess in this example like I don't
really see how it's going to work
because you see those the point of these
rather macro bounds is that okay at the
end you get something that depends on
the X I but when you get to the final
bound where you say it's just a folder 1
over square root n or something like
that
you have forgotten everything about the
data yeah yeah
so what I'm saying is that this is a
Napper bound so you can imagine trying
to do something more refined than this
which could maybe go around it so that's
why I'm gonna tell you the next example
where there's nothing you can do because
there is no denying nothing you just
need more data
okay it's very simple
so I lost track of what example it was
its example for
it's really a real robot because even
the VC argument is also just an
upper-bound example for and this is
taken from a sopressata the different
paper from the first one excited so it
goes like this it's very well yeah okay
I should stop saying it's very simple so
you know I just have a Teta of nom one
option is no Mon on the sphere and I
have two distribution X conditioned on y
equals plus one this is just going to be
distributed from a Gaussian centered at
data and we've covariant some constant
over squared D times the identity I will
explain this scaling in a minute and X
conditioned on y equals minus one this
is gonna be from n Tesla constant over
square minus theta constant over squared
times y n okay so I have two high
dimensional gaussians which are
separated at distance 1 and AB this type
of coherence ok so notice that if you
are one of us curve D you can still go
pretty far in terms of l2 norm if you
sum all of the distances so naively they
overlap and up a lot but of course
because of high dimensions they are not
gonna really overlap so what do I mean
by this
so claim 1 1 sample
is enough to get close to 100% accuracy
teenagers
so why is that
so let's say let's say I get one sample
from from each you know from the plus 1
and the minus 1 it doesn't change
anything so really the way I think about
this is that I have my - that I have my
plus theta and then I have this high
dimensional thing the 3d is kind of
focused in this band of size 1 over
squared D but now you know there are
lots of dimension over here so maybe you
know my theta hat is here this is my
theta hat and maybe my minus theta hat
is I mean this dress here minus theta
okay so they are pretty far from the
real theta and now I get a sample this
is this is my sample X that I want to
classify because the only reasonable
thing to do is to class to assign it to
the closes between theta hat and minus
theta hat now what's going to happen is
that so if I look at the distance of X
to theta hat minus the distance of X to
minus theta okay let's say I look at the
distance squared so I have a bunch of of
terms ok I have D terms one per
dimension one of them is gonna be large
I can imagine theta it's just the first
coordinate you know I can rotate so that
theta is the first coordinate so one of
them is going to be of order one this is
going to be a further bias which is 1
plus D terms plus a sum of terms
what are those terms they have zero mean
doesn't prefer you know on the
coordinate which are irrelevant I'm
either closer to that - you know this
point or to the other one that it's it's
okay which one it is so I have a bunch
of term which are brands 1 over squared
D and they have zero mean so the total
number that I get is square of D times
this so I get plus AB squared D times
this constant of a squared D so let me
explain again I have a bunch of terms
which have zero mean and whose
expectation is constant over Square D
whose the expected sorry of the square
is constant over Square D so the total
amount of situation is a photo scroll
gee that's a cancellation so I get score
D times constant over Square D so this
is going to be let me say what I want to
say this is going to be strictly
positive okay if this constant is small
enough then my bias overcomes the burns
so if the constant here is small enough
I know that with just one sample I can
classify any new example I just assign
it to the closest point but now what
happens with adverse our examples we fat
versus our examples the only things that
happen is that instead of having F
squared D here with a dress for example
I get D terms here because I can modify
each of those terms so I don't get the
squared D fluctuations of of the iid
difference between those distance but I
can just push everyone in the worst
possible direction and hang on you're
not happy this is just a one-dimensional
division so no it's not one-dimensional
because there is noise so theta hat you
see that is gonna be there will be the
bias direction the signal direction but
that art is gonna have you know in
dimension - it's gonna be I don't know
point 1 in dimension 3 is going to be
1.5 so there with one sample there is a
bunch of noise but I don't know it yeah
yeah of course
yes but at the point you don't know if
you if you didn't know it then yes the
point is you don't know it yeah and in
fact as we were just discussing so what
are those also dimension coming from it
comes from the noise so now let's assume
that AB and sample then the bands is
going to go down as like 1 over N so I
get 1 over n if I have many samples so
you see that for this term to be small
compared to 1 I need so now I have G
times 1 over squared D times 1 over N
and I would like this to be much smaller
than one which is the same thing as n is
much bigger than Square D so you see
that with clean accuracy just one sample
was enough but with address L accuracy I
basically I remove the CLT if you want I
cannot use the CLT anymore with address
all examples so now what happens is that
instead of n being 1 I need Square D
examples yeah yes yes yes so the point
is now we've addressed our examples
you're not going to look at X the
distance of X 2 Delta Theta hat when I
look at the distance of X plus Delta so
I can do a push this and result push and
what I'm saying is that I can exactly
make the adverse or push match the noise
so that in every direction
I push so that every term you know goes
the wrong direction which is let's say
negative infinity so my assumption is
that the any Trinity no yeah you're
right
the an infinity norm is like 1 so what
second yeah but it's an infinity no so
I'm allowed to push in every coordinate
if it was an - this wouldn't work maybe
that's your yeah yes yes so that's yes
indeed this only works for infinity some
of the stuff that I say only works for
infinity some only works for - pretty
annoying
okay and it's very easy to make this a
completely form or argument just make
you know this a Bayesian problem and
then you can just work on what is the
posterior distribution of theta means it
and I said that I wouldn't say very
simple
[Music]
okay some more examples quickly let's go
to three which was more compute so here
is a very simple example it gonna take
some time myself Eric price and idea
resin stein yeah okay so what I want to
show to you here so first of all we
already so that maybe you need more
compute if you're being very naive
because like with linear classifiers
just in the W space the address or
training might be non-contact although
if you lift then it becomes non-contact
it becomes complex by the way this was
observed in 2006 by a grue person and
raw rice the point of this example is
going to be like this one to show that
in fact job very natural examples where
there's nothing you can do there's no
lifting there is there's just nothing
you can do so here is the most naive
version of the example and I won't
explain the more refined one so the most
naive version is going to be like this
so X conditioned on y equals plus one
it's just gonna be uniform on the hyper
cube uniform on minus 1 1 and then what
is going to be X conditioned on y equals
-1 it's gonna be so I want an example
where there exists a robust classifier
something very robust it's not like it's
hard to do robust classification there
exists something extremely robust but
you just cannot find it computationally
and the way I'm going to do that is that
I'm gonna have another distribution
which is very different from uniform yet
computationally you cannot distinguish
it from uniform so that's that has a
name that's called a pseudo random
generator just to observe a random
generator on minus 1 1 so what is absurd
a random generator it takes a seed which
is smaller than this dimension let's say
D over 2 and out of deal with 2 real
and emits it produced the pseudo random
bits so computationally they look
completely random but the point is if
this is the hypercube and I have you
know those have to 2 to the D over 2
boards like this of radius big radius
let's say radius so this is a further
squared D local board and this is a
photo of square with D over 2 okay so I
have this board I have 2 to the D over 2
boards these are the real support like
this is the support of the pseudo-random
generator the pseudo-random generator is
going to be one of those spots the point
is that all of the ball of radius
squared D over 2 for all of these points
this is still a microscopic mass of the
global right oq this is still
exponentially small in this big cube so
that means that there exists a very
robust classifier for this thing the
very robust as firewood no ok here is
the support of the episode or random
generator if I get a point here I say
it's plus 1 if I get a point here I say
it's minus 1 and this is robust I cannot
do any perturbation to this and confuse
it because and the plus 1 I'm never
gonna fall in this board
I mean I'm gonna fall in these boards
which exponentially small probability so
one thing you might be unhappy with
about this example so again this this
shows that I have examples that live in
a bowl of size curve D there exists a
classifier which is robust up to
perturbation of size quality so like
maximally robust I can change almost
everything and still I can tell where it
came from
yet computationally I cannot do anything
I just I'm completely lost even for
clean accuracy so of course I can change
the example to make it to the clean
accuracy is good but so one complaint
that you might have is that this robust
classifier is itself very complicated
you know it has to know the supporters
of pseudo-random generators which is you
know not something that is succinctly
describable but you can modify the
examples through what's called backdoor
pseudo-random
right oh and basically the back dope to
the random generator so it has a key
where if you know the key then you can
tell the difference between the two okay
so I won't get into yes yeah so yes
maybe you're not happy about discrete
also so in fact two papers and the one
is with hint that America love months
later so in the so this is actually the
construction from the second paper which
is really simple and and as maximal
perturbation in the first paper we did
something more continuous whereas the
noise was you know the the true noise
was Gaussian and the perturbation was a
structured noise so basically you just
hide a subspace of size G over two of
dimension D over 2 and on that subspace
you discretize the Gaussian
you just have a globe or Gaussian and
then there is some subspace where it's
not really Gaussian it's a discretized
Gaussian so if you could search over all
subspace you would find a subspace where
I it's funny you know all the points
they fall on this grid but you cannot
search over all subspaces and this is a
statistical query lower bound in fact
there are some follow up in the works
not by us that shows that this first
example is also hard under cryptographic
assumptions but so it's even it goes
even beyond the statistical query model
okay not to things that the two quick
things that I want to say so for it we
are doomed right so of course there is
this assumption that for images we
should be able to to have a robust
classifier because humans exist and we
seem to be robust it it's very hard to
believe that you know I could modify a
few pixel and then suddenly I believe
I'm on the beach so it's very hard to
believe but on the other hand it's also
I think slightly under estimating the
exponential power of you know all the
modifications that I could make to this
image it's it's very hard to tell so so
I don't know I don't know the truth I
don't know if no scientists are thinking
about this question I don't know if it's
possible to set up an experiment to test
it but in any case what we can say is
that there are very simple models where
you can show that address or example are
inevitable
okay now papers coming on the archive
almost every month all saying the same
thing and I don't understand what they
are saying is is the following
it's just isoparametric just Gaussian
concentration so the nice paper I think
on this is a fuzzy fuzzy and Fuzzy's
three browsers in 2018 so here is the
model if you want it - it's a gun model
these are actually very seriously so the
model is like this X is going to be some
function G of Z where Z is some Gaussian
okay so you have a latent variable which
is Gaussian and then you just have some
neural network you know whatever some
function that produce the image or the
example okay this is gonna be one
Lipschitz okay so this is your model and
the point is that in this model there
are Idris all examples probably why is
that so say to balance classes this was
a boaster probability 1/2 there is a
forty one half of a plus 1/4 to 1/2 4
minus 1 into this model
the picture is like this this is a minus
1 this is a plus 1 and they have the
distribution which is you know the image
to push forward of the Gaussian through
this Lipschitz function G and the point
if is if this is of mass 1/2 and this is
of mass 1/2 then the Gaussian is a
parametric tells you that if you expand
this a little bit you know by just all 1
some constant then in fact within this
region all of this here you have 90% of
the mass ok so you had one half of the
mass here and then you just go a
constant further away and you have
ninety percent of the mass so this means
that 90% of the mass you know it's it's
near I mean you know and I have the same
thing the other way around yeah yeah
very good so it's in this space
naturally but then because G is
Lipschitz it's also in X space right
because J is 1 Lipschitz and the typical
size of X is going to be squared D so
the typical size R squared D and I have
example of size a constant so this is
kind of one argument
so then okay you need to make more
options assumptions about gee this is
like for general G which is just one
Lipschitz
if you're saying if I was thinking about
real images and it should be on on this
supposedly manifold of images or
something like that is that what you're
saying oh yeah even more
high-dimensional sure yeah so this is
this is the simplest model where let's
say X is in our D and D is an object is
just changing a little bit to
distribution but of course you can you
can modify this example as much as you
sure but people will complain that you
know these are not and right for you by
the way that Gaussian images don't look
like real images I guess a big point of
all of this is really that on the
contrary to classical statistical
learning theory we will need to make
assumptions on the distribution if we
want to make progress on this problem
just and without assumption you run into
all of these problems one Lipschitz
transformational version
ganz yes yeah actually actually what is
the problem of this example it is the
one Lipschitz that's not reasonable okay
now our networks are not one Lipschitz
that's right but it's still a cute
example okay let me conclude very
quickly with certification which is I
think where the more interesting
progress is happening right now
so certification so let's say you take
those numbers that I told you at the
beginning fifty-seven percent and forty
three percent and these are empirical
numbers how do you guarantee that your
network is really robust up to those
levels okay you cannot test or the
exponentially many perturbations so
there are essentially two approaches to
this problem so one is formulate
verification as a sub problem if you as
program or mixed integer linear program
so of course you're not going to get
anything I mean it's not going to work
in the worst case but you can run V on
Sat solver or real you know mixed
integer linear program solvers and if it
outputs a certificate then you know you
guaranteed that it's good that it's
certified and the way it works is they
exist you just want to say here is the
question you have this set the set of
Delta let's say in the cube minus 1 1 to
the D such that let's say you manage to
make class I F I of X plus Delta you
manage to make it more likely than class
J
okay so again F is the output of my
network so f is a function from Rd
talking I have K classes and all I want
to know is does there exist a delta
where let's say j.j was a real class I
mean the class outputted on X and I want
to know that there exists a delta such
that F is the coordinate I becomes
bigger when I do plus Delta compared to
class J and I want to know is this set
empty if this set is empty and I have
certified the down-low
address all examples now this function
are just network okay neural networks
the bunch of the operation in our
networks are just mini operations are
just a couple of nonlinear operation the
most famous one of course is the value
yes this is exist
I am J yeah no no let's fix I and J
depends on I'll just send depends on ing
absolutely you you want to know you have
to class i MJ you want to know can you
make this class I more likely than this
class J and of course you're going to
try this with let's say J is the most
likely class under X and is the second
most likely but this is for any two
class so the only non-trivial things is
to represent the value as a as an
integer program so I would just write
the formula because I I find it nice
yeah it's super simple but
so I want to write why is the positive
part of X as an integer program and what
I will need is also upper bound and
lower bounds on X okay and basically the
complexity of my program is going to
depend on U and L and then there are
lots and lots of papers trying to
optimize over finding the smallest you
and L that you can using all the
information I won't get into that so the
way you write this is like this this is
the equivalent to okay why is certainly
bigger than x and y is certainly bigger
than zero and then I just gonna have an
integer variable a which is going to
tell me whether Y is actually X or 0 and
the way it could work is like this why
it's more than a times u so you see if a
is equal to 1 this tells me nothing
because I know that X is smaller than
ooh but if a is equal to 0 then Y is
more than 0 and Y bigger than 0 this
tells me Y is 0 n equals 0 is only
consistent of course if 0 is bigger than
X right because a equals 0 if I plug in
a called 0 then I have a contradiction
if X is bigger than 0 and then I have
the other one y is smaller than a times
L plus X minus L is the same thing now
if a is equal to 1 so if a is equal to 1
what do I get I get that Y is smaller
than X so I get Y is equal to X and if Y
if a is equal to 0 I use this one okay
so this inequalities which are all
linear in Y and a that the point is that
there is nothing like a times X there is
nothing nonlinear it's linear in a and
and x and y this represents the value so
you can just write this set as some kind
of integer polytope then you can run all
those solvers and I will conclude with
the last idea which I think is the
nicest so Sebastian here protecting
yourself against all possible images
potential
you know juice yes is there any
reasonable for relation to only protect
yourself against reasonably like
perturbations of reasonable images yeah
you say like instead of I mean what what
is the reasonable image questions okay
so here you you want to certify that
their network is good for all X's and
for all perturbations of these X's
you're given X this said sorry this said
depends on X yeah yeah only on on some
fixed X you want to certify the other
you're only gonna certify them the tests
internal training self yeah there may be
some other demos that's not on your test
yeah so in fact I'm not a huge fan of
this but the next one will do that okay
so that was if you serve on a random
tester right then you can generalize
because certification is zero property
and then dependent of your network then
but it might be that you want to apply
to a completely different distribution
yeah okay so the last idea is just how
do you I mean certification is very
closely related to the Lipschitz nice
property of your network so you can't
assume anything about the Lipschitz
nests of of F because our networks are
not typically Lipschitz so you can try
to train to enforce Lipschitz nests and
things like that but this hasn't been
very successful what you can do though
is to take a train network and smooth it
and what's the most natural smoothing
it's to do a Gaussian convolution okay
so this is called randomized smoothing
randomize smoothing what you do is that
you have F which is this function from
Rd to R K and you transform it into F
hat which is a convolution of F with a
small Gaussian let's say your Gaussian
with covariance Sigma Sigma times the
identity and the point is that F hat so
let's say this takes value in 0 1 to the
K right it just gives you a probability
for each class f hat is 1 over Sigma
Lipshitz this is a to lines
calculation so now what happens so the
claim now the very simple claim is that
you can let Delta to be a Phi of X minus
F J of X ok and let's assume this is
positive ok so this is a gap between the
priority of class I and the priority of
class J then the point is that for F hat
sorry I want F hat the point is that for
this network if you predict using f hat
you know that there are no address for
example in a neighborhood of size
epsilon which is Delta time Sigma then
epsilon equals Delta time Sigma is
robust
the only slight problem is that you
cannot really compute F hat this is a
high dimensional integral but you can
approximate it very well by just
sampling so you can sample and you get
to probabilistic guarantee you get that
with you know 99.99 percent probability
the network at this example is going to
be very robust with this robustness and
this can really be used so so now we
have a paper coming up with a dish
almond sauce or mannitol and a bunch of
people at Microsoft where so this is a
follow up on a very nice paper by Jeremy
Cohen at all at CMU and in fact follow
up on the whole line of work maybe just
one name is Zico quarter and the
students they have a lot of work on this
and in fact the previous paper including
paper by Daniel I don't know if he is
here and many of the people but now this
really works so we did address all
training so there is a story about the
fact that they didn't get the right
objective and we we derive the right
objective using this convolution view
and the punchline is that at the end we
get accuracy which is comparable or even
better than the best empirical accuracy
but now it's provable the catch is this
works for l2 so this Lipschitz is an l2
Lipchitz property so this doesn't work
this doesn't give you provable
guarantees for L infinity for infinity
you will get some dimension dependency
and just it becomes basically back to a
scream but while too you can guarantee
and you can get state-of-the-art
performances so all of this thing you
know at the end there is what Costas is
saying about you know the right norm
about how how do you say what is natural
images what is not a natural image then
there is the fact that for l2 we have
some tools which are more powerful than
for an infinity yeah I don't know where
all of this is going but I find it very
exciting ok I will stop here Thanks
since it's five o'clock and some people
have to leave let's go ahead and take
questions offline